clotilde est l'une des premières jeunes
a bénéficié de la réforme de
l'apprentissage
elle poursuit sa formation dans la même
école privée que l'année dernière mais
pour sa seconde année en bts professions
immobilières
elle a trouvé un employeur qui lui a
signé un contrat d'apprentissage
l'année dernière j'étais en formation
initiale donc j'ai financé ma formation
j'ai été obligé de travailler en plus à
côté donc en plus de mon stage en plus
de l'école nous travaillons le soir le
week-end les vacances scolaires alors
que l'as vu que tu financer je peux me
consacrer entièrement à ma formation
depuis la rentrée
cent vingt élèves de cette école de
formation aux métiers du tertiaire ont
signé un contrat d'apprentissage
avant seuls les contrats de
professionnalisation était possible pour
ce type d'établissement privé
on va faire des choses qui étaient
normalement réservé au cfa donc d'une
certaine manière oui c'est une ouverture
à la concurrence mais moi je vous dis
j'avais le but final qui est la serre
sont des jeunes sur le marché du travail
mais l'ouverture de l'apprentissage nous
permet de nous développer davantage et
les 52 centres de formation des
apprentis de la région sont directement
confrontés à cette ouverture à la
concurrence
on change de système avec un réel
bouleversement des modèles économiques
et organisationnels de nos cfa pour son
discours de rentrée le directeur de ce
cfa affiche d'emblée son ambition ces
enseignants et l'équipe administrative
ou un peu plus d'un an pour s'adapter
il ya une libéralisation de l'offre de
formation terre que demain il ya de la
concurrence qui va être encore plus
importante que par le passé et je pense
que vraiment très objectivement la
démarche qualité la qualité la
certification qualité
ça va être une des priorités pour pour
nos cfa historique des embauches sont
même prévus pour développer le marketing
et la communication de ce cfa
mais cette mise en concurrence peut
fragiliser certains centres d'apprentis
c'est ce que craint le conseil régional
de bourgogne franche comté avec la
nouvelle loi ces collectivités ont perdu
leur
deux financeurs avant les régions versé
au cfa une enveloppe pour cinq ans de
fonctionnement
maintenant ce sont d'autres organismes
qui finançons les cfa pour chaque
contrat signé au coup par coup c'est un
peu l'anarchie qui va s'installer sur
les sur les territoires sans en fonction
des besoins des entreprises le respect
des besoins à court terme le risque que
c'est des formations par forcément de
très bonne qualité partout et tout ce
travail de prospective pour imaginer la
carte des formations idéal de demain ce
qui est très important
on voit un petit peu que l'on va on va
dans le flou et on a peur pour certains
certaines filières et certains
territoires cette réforme en profondeur
de l'apprentissage va se mettre
progressivement en place
en bourgogne franche comté on dénombre
pour 2010 9 900 apprentis
supplémentaires par rapport à l'année
dernière soit un peu plus de vingt mille
jeunes